foreign gke provides built-in
functionality to help you optimize your
kubernetes clusters so let's dive right
into it
we'll take a look at these features
Through The Eyes of two gke clusters one
standard and one autopilot
let's start by visiting the cost
optimization tab from our clusters page
in the console
this tab we can see a Time series
visualization for our gke clusters which
will get detailed information about
resources across clusters in a project
in this case starting with CPU across
all standard clusters
for any given time over a customizable
time window in this case one month
we can see the total allocatable CPU
across all of our standard clusters the
amount of CPU actually requested by pods
running in those clusters and the amount
of CPU actually used by these pods
we can also see bar charts below to show
us what usage requests and allocatable
resources looked like over that defined
time window
now this information can definitely help
us understand how efficiently we bin
pack our workloads onto nodes in our
cluster
but what it can also do is give us
insight into scale down efficiency
for example we can use the time filter
to take a look at a specific window in
which we had a scale-up event so let's
take a look at this one
now we can see that while we added nodes
during the scale up of pod requests we
could have gotten better cluster
utilization by prioritizing scale down
after usage had stabilized
information like this can help us make
optimization-centric decisions like
implementing the optimize utilization
profile for cluster Auto scaler which
was not enabled in our cluster during
this time window
a change like that will not only help
cluster Auto scalers spin down
underutilized nodes better but will also
give preference to scheduling pods on
nodes with more usage to improve cluster
bin packing
we can also get the same visualization
from memory across our standard clusters
as well
in this case we can see that our
clusters still have a bunch of
unallocated memory
with this data we can think about
optimization decisions like choosing
machine types with less memory in our
clusters
time series visualization also supports
gke autopilot clusters
okay
one of the core differences between GK
standard mode and GK autopilot mode is
the fact that Google manages your
underlying node infrastructure in
autopilot thus it handles the amount of
allocatable resources for you in the
cluster
so in this model you don't pay for
infrastructure used or idle but rather
you pay for your pod requests
thus our optimization efforts focus on
whether or not pods are using the
resources that they request
as you can see across both memory and
CPU there is opportunity to perform
workload right sizing that is adjusting
pod requests to reduce resource waste
while still requesting what the Pod
needs to function
not only does this cost optimization tab
show us data on resource utilization
across clusters but also links us
directly to its financial implications
as each cluster I've shown you here has
gke cost allocation enabled which is
integrated with Cloud billing
when we click on view billing reports
we're navigated to Cloud billing with
information about the cost of our
clusters however in many cases clusters
housed many workloads across multiple
teams what if we want to understand
costs at a more granular level that can
help us identify areas to optimize
with GK cost allocation we can filter
billing data down to the cost of pod
requests by namespace or labels across
our clusters in this case some filtering
based on namespaces
this is yet another reason to double
check that you're using namespaces and
labels to logically organize and
identify teams and services in your
clusters another helpful bit here is
that we can also see the cost of
unallocated resources in our cluster
This Cloud billing data can also be
exported to bigquery and it includes all
gcp resources not just gke
this means you can do things like write
SQL queries to parse not only What A
team's workloads are costing in gke but
also backing in staple Services those
workloads might consume outside of gke
like Cloud memory store Cloud SQL Etc
a sensible Next Step once we reviewed
some of this information at the macro
level is to get more granular so let's
navigate to the cost optimization tab in
the workload section of the gke console
foreign
for simplicity's sake let's filter this
view down to our standard cluster
this tab gives us helpful cost
optimization data per workload in which
we can see similar time series
M bar graph visualizations
to understand how workload usage relates
to their requests and limits over a
defined time window
so let's review each one by one
we'll start with our Alpha workload
our Alpha workload uses about 50 percent
of its requested resources but only
about a quarter of its memory requested
resources
it's an opportunity to perhaps reduce
requests across both but especially
memory
our beta workload is also around 50
percent of its CPU requests
but this time its memory usage well
exceeds its requests
this is noted here by our yellow bar
graph
this is an opportunity to not only set
requests higher but as you can see we
don't have any limits set for memory but
we should
Without Limits this workload can consume
too much memory on a node that could
create out of memory problems for other
workloads on that node
our Delta workload is unfortunately
representative of a common problem
workloads without requests or limit set
this creates the same Noisy Neighbor
problem of workloads consuming too much
of a node's resources but it also does
not help us at all when it comes to
Cluster bin packing after all the
cluster can bin pack as good as our
requests are when they are set
finally we see the gamma workload in
which we have an opportunity to increase
the CPU resource request amount but we
also see in its memory usage what the
bar graph looks like
when we have limits appropriately set
as our limit here is defined by the gray
this data can help us Implement cost
optimization as part of a cultural shift
in which cluster admins work with
service owners to adjust these requests
not only to course correct but also to
implement best practices and standards
moving forward around requests and
limits
as teams work together gke bubbles up
easily accessible information that can
help them in workload right sizing
so let's take a look at our beta
workload in which we can see some of
vertical pod Auto scalers
recommendations directly in the console
epa's recommendations are based on the
workloads historical and current usage
we can start by taking a look at the
actions menu navigating to scale and
selecting edit resource requests
here with the green lines denoted by the
star icon we can see recommended values
to set for CPU and memory requests
if you remember our beta workloads
memory usage well exceeds its requests
so we can see that reflected in the
recommendation to increase our memory
requests
let's now take a look at the alpha
workload
foreign
for workloads with HPA based on a usage
threshold of CPU like the alpha workload
here changing CPU requests in isolation
can have unintended effects thus no
recommendation is provided
however we do still get a recommended
value to set for memory requests
this data can help teams work in tandem
to workload right size in order to yield
better cluster optimization at Large
now this functionality covered up to
this point is great for teams already
running gke clusters but what about for
those who are looking to get started
with gke on the right foot with cost
optimization top of mind
if you're creating your first GK cluster
and want to be set up for success and
optimization we have a couple ways in
the console to help
the first is our setup guide for a cost
optimized gke standard cluster in which
we have a wizard that you can use to
create your cluster using a template in
the UI
this template includes a lot of the
things we talked about today
cluster Auto scaling with the optimize
utilization profile vertical pod Auto
scaling gke cost allocation
but of course the wizard also allows you
to make certain changes you need for
your cluster
I prefer to use the console and
configure your cluster bit by bit we'll
also provide estimations into what your
cluster might cost as you build it out
if you plan on auto scaling your cluster
we provide a slider that will give you
an idea of the range of the cost of your
cluster as it changes due to demand
foreign
as we conclude I'd like to reiterate
that optimization is a team effort
between cluster admins workload owners
and even billing managers an effort that
must continuously happen as new
workloads on board and existing
workloads change
as we saw in this tour gke provides many
pieces of built-in features to help you
in your journey to optimize your gke
clusters to learn more check out the
links in the description below my name
is Anthony Bouchon and thank you for
your time